[Music]
foreign
while Karma may be her boyfriend sources
confirmed that Taylor Swift is living
the single life after her fling with the
1975's Maddie Healy that's right despite
a previous report hinting that the
Grammy award-winning artist was still
secretly seeing the 1975 front man a
source tells people that the musicians
are no longer linked stating they are
absolutely not together and aren't even
in contact anymore she is enjoying being
single and has been spending time in the
studio and hanging out with friends in
New York City this is all Bs with a
source that's close to Maddie adds it's
complete nonsense not true at all
so I guess it's safe to say that the
story of them is done as Swift focuses
on the next chapter of her life which
includes speak now Taylor's version
[Music]
next chapter but honestly we are not
surprised they're both busy touring and
a source previously confirmed this is a
big reason they called it quits telling
people her Focus right now is her tour
since Maddie is touring too they won't
be able to see each other at all they
have been friends for years and decided
to just go back to being friends nothing
complicated happened it's just life
Taylor is doing great and another
Insider told page six back in June that
everyone who really knows her has been
saying all along that this was a fun
good time thing that would last as long
as it lasted and would be no big deal
once it was done well as long as
Taylor's doing great so are us swifties
now if she'd only respond to Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's plea on
Twitter asking when us Canadians can
expect era tour dates then we can all be
doing great as for now guess we'll have
to stream speak now Taylor's version
it's ever been
[Music]